MALE SPEAKER: Google Code Jam
is the largest individual
programming competition
in the world.
This is our 10th year
of running it.
And this year, the finals
are in London.
This year, 45,000 people have
registered to compete in Code
Jam, starting with a
qualification round,
proceeding through three
online rounds.
And the final 25 have
been invited to
the finals in London.
The finalists will compete for
a prize of $15,000 and the
title of Code Jam champion.
The finalists this year are
going to be solving some
interesting problems.
Some examples of problems from
past years involved four-armed
monsters sorting numbers,
grapple hook swinging ninjas.
This year, one of the problems
is about finding a drummer for
your rock band.
PIEGUY: Hi, my name
is David Stolp.
My handle is pieguy.
I actually go by pieguy most of
the time, so I don't mind
if people call me pieguy.
I'm here representing the United
States of America.
This is my first Code
Jam finals.
Woo-hoo!
VASYL: Hello.
My name is Vasyl, and
I am from Ukraine.
I believe this is my fourth time
at the Code Jam finals.
STANIEK: I really like it
because it's something between
theory and practice.
And I generally like both.
JPAULSON: The coding
competitions are sort of like
the essence of what's fun about
computer science, I think.
You get a very clean problem,
well defined.
You get to figure out the
solution, code it up, and see
if you're right, all within
like an hour.
So it's a very compressed
experience of what I find fun
about computer science.
PO: Another great thing about
the Code Jam, which I enjoyed
very much as an alum, is that
it brings together the
finalists in a common venue
where they can exchange ideas
and often form partnerships and
friendships which extend
many years beyond.
I will say that is one thing
that brought me back here to
go hunt for the Code Jam
in the London offices.
This is a wonderful community
that you've created.